so eric trump not known as the smartest
of the trump children
he now uh made the claim
that the
raid as he calls it on trump's
mar-a-lago
will lead to a terrorist attack the
logic there is because 30 agents were at
mar-a-lago last monday
then some terrorist attack won't be
prevented because everybody's too busy
it's a very very strange thing i miss
this when he gave this interview take a
look this doesn't happen i know greg i
know this apparatus very well as you do
this does not happen without
presidential consent you know the white
house new mark my word they're out there
today saying that no one in the white
house knew this was a hundred percent
mark my word directed by the white house
this is a
political hit on my father uh they know
biden's floundering the polls he's doing
absolutely horrible and so what did they
do they put on a stunt like this and you
know i want everybody to remember god
forbid i hate having to say this but if
there's ever another terrorist attack in
this country if there's ever another
school shooting in this country the next
time you see a serial killer in this
country
i want everybody to remember that the
fbi
spent all their resources going into
mar-a-lago to look for
you know effectively records for a
public library right you know right
imagine a trump library everything would
be written in crayon other than being
focused on china who's ripping off
america every single day rather than
being focused on the threats that plague
this country terrorism that wants to
come in here al qaeda you know
the taliban so many other people who
want to destroy our way of life
extremists who want to destroy our way
of life
the fbi because of joe biden and because
of this incompetent administration has
weaponized the system there's no
evidence biden had anything to do with
it
to go after their political rivals
and that's their priority versus keeping
this country safe i want everybody to
remember that because you better believe
we're going to see one of these
instances again
and it's going to be because their eye
was off the ball
that is a devastating way to put it i
hadn't thought about it that way and
you're absolutely right yeah the fbi is
known for despite having 35 000
employees the fbi only works on one case
at a time famous the fb they literally
all the field offices across the country
35 000 employees one case at a time and
because they spent a few hours at
mar-a-lago
terrorism will now not be stopped these
people are nuts and they're dangerous
but unfortunately their followers hear
these talking points and they just
repeat them uncritically
let me know what you think find me on
twitter at dpakman tomorrow we will be
joined by producer pat who will be
hosting the show the next couple days
then farron cousins from ring of fire
will be hosting a couple days after that
and then i will be back with stories of
peace and love also remember that
wednesday august 31st at 6 pm we will
have the members only david pakman show
town hall
this is a town hall like the others
we've done
except it will be open
only to members don't worry we're going
to get back to the wide open town halls
as well we're just doing one
members only town hall i would love for
you to participate and you can do so
simply by being a member at
joinpacman.com
i've talked on the show before about how
we have dealt with hacking and it's a
terrible feeling you have to act quickly
the problem can get worse fast if you
don't and i now protect myself with aura
aura monitors my email addresses
passwords bank accounts credit cards all
of that stuff and sends me alerts if
anything has been compromised it's
identity theft protection and fraud
monitoring all wrapped together aura
continuously monitors the dark web
looking for your private info you get an
alert as soon as something is discovered
aura also does things like alert you if
there are suspicious credit inquiries if
someone opens or tries to open an
account in your name i've gotten useful
alerts from my aura app and i was able
to act on them quickly if you don't have
a tool like aura i highly recommend it
and when you go to aura.com pacman you
will get aura free for 14 days which you
can use to do things like see if your
passwords have been leaked the link is
down below